we decided that we would celebrate the
one year anniversary of our film what is
a woman and ring in pride month 2023 by
releasing the film free for everybody on
Twitter and we presented this idea to
Twitter several weeks ago they were
excited about it but then only a few
days before our streaming event Twitter
changed its tune dramatically told us
that they decided that the film is hate
speech and that it violates its policies
against misgendering quote unquote there
was no clear resolution then on the
issue last night it was kind of still up
in the air we're going to show what's
going on at some point overnight the
hateful conduct flag was removed from
the film and sharing and retweeting was
enabled I started getting messages from
people saying that not only could they
share but the movie was coming up in
their feed and a few hours later as the
ultimate Capstone on all of this drama
Elon Musk himself shared the film from
his account with a caption urging every
parent to watch it so how do we make
sense of this when it comes to Twitter I
think the most reasonable interpretation
is that Elon Musk is still fighting with
the leftist radical elements in his own
company